what is that smoke jumping stuff so
basically it's um you know about
Wildland firefighting about when the
forest has fires
there's a lot of times there's roads and
there's access to get there so these you
know whether it be a
Hot Shot crew or whatever these
different Crews who come in by vehicle
they can get into the fire that way what
a smoke jumper is is you can't get a
vehicle into that place
it is a spot where it's tight there's no
vehicles there's no access
so they'll send us in there smoke
jumpers jump out of airplanes and we'll
land in these really tight small Drop
Zones with all of our gear and we'll put
the fire out
how do you take Walter in we jump out so
everything is hang on you're jumping out
of a airplane parachute with
backpacks of water like a camel pack
type thing so we'll jump out we'll have
this it's called a ditty pack and it and
it sits in you know it sits like by your
waist you know yep on your legs area
when you jump out and that has a lot of
your gear but what happens is once you
jump out the aircraft would go lower and
will push out
all the rest of your gear your water
pumps oh and that'll get air dropped in
with its own little parachutes right
right so a lot of our main gear gets
dropped into us and then we're out there
for several days until the fire is put
out by us and only us
that's insane it's insane yeah why'd you
do that
well when I left the military
um you're I'm always looking for more
I'm always looking for what's the next
thing for myself how can I grow
and that right there was the next thing
for me you know I didn't want to sit
back and you know just enjoy my
retirement for the military that's
there's there's no growth in that so I
decided to go out and do this
so you jump out of an airplane with a
team you get your kit also parachuted
out of the back you're now in the middle
of an area where there's no Evac there's
no vehicles that can come and get you
there's a fire you need to put the fire
out and you don't stop until you're done
that's it
sometimes there is a way to get out but
a lot of times it's just you know if
someone gets hurt on the jump a lot of
times we have to build like cut down a
bunch of trees so a helicopter can come
in land and get them out so we are the
only access
we have to save ourselves
so a lot of times we are the team to get
us in and to get us out what was the
longest
Mission exercise I think the longest one
I deal with seven days
so and what's the sort of daily routine
are you sleeping do you get much sleep
at all no not really so what happens is
and the thing about being in Canada so I
do this out of uh out of British
Columbia
so what happens is there's a lot of
daylight
so when I'm out there man there's a lot
of daylight in the middle of the summer
when it's hot when you've got tons of
right okay that's right so there's not
much there's not much dark so you're
basically working a lot of hours so and
then when it gets dark you're actually
working through the night time and then
you get a little you know you get a
little rest and you wake up and you add
it again
and then when the fire is out you Patrol
the fire make sure there's no more hot
spots make sure everything is black and
wet because we we literally wet the
whole area down so there's no hot spots
and then that's all done
we'll demo which means we'll clean up
all the stuff all our hoses you know
we'll we'll pack up all our stuff and
then we'll we'll get out of there did
you ask because we paid for this I
I get about I think that the pay is
about 12 to 15 bucks an hour
so it was funny about it man like when I
first started doing this job
um
people
didn't know that you know I'm actually
successful in business
and then it realized that I was like
basically turned down millions of
dollars to do this job and they can
continue thinking it to make 15 books to
make 15 bucks an hour so yeah but you
know like I said for me the the whole
money part of it it's it's not what it's
about
I'm all about that growth and that
growth isn't in these massive paychecks
for speaking to corporations stuff like
that the growth for me is in that 12 to
15 an hour when you're out there and
it's like
20 you know 20 degrees and you're
freezing your ass off and you're
thinking you know what I don't need to
be here anymore
and you start questioning yourself while
you're here and there's a lot of growth
in that
why did you decide to release another
book what Was undone with the first one
well the first one was basically
um a bachelor's degree
with the mind is how I look at it and no
one knew who I was so this is the book
never finished is the book that I wanted
to come out first
but how am I going to get so deep into
something when no one knows who the hell
I am
so first I have to give you some
backstory on who the hell David Goggins
is some credentials that's it and so I
got some basic credentials out there
and now I can dive in more because most
people think I'm just some good animal
who runs and yells and just says [__]
[__] all the time and that's
nowhere near the truth that's maybe what
they see in a one minute video that's
what people believe but there's a lot of
thought behind a person being a born
loser
becoming who I am today you'll just wake
up and just Rocky the [__] you gotta
wake up and think about you know there's
a process to getting better
and that process is never finished
it's an appropriate title so one of the
things I've been thinking about is the
danger of success making you soft and
this must be something that you've
battled with over the last few years
right more money more attention more
Fame more free things if you wanted more
opportunities to go places and do stuff
with people right how have you
dealt with this battle of success not
making you soft you have to cap it
you have to learn to cap success
so what I do is like right now
I don't like doing podcasts there's a
lot of things I don't do have to do now
to get the messages out there to help
people out
and what I mean by capping success I
believe everybody should live their life
so everything that someone says in life
take it with a grain of salt
take what they give and don't be like oh
David goggin said this or whoever said
this no
do not take what I say and do exactly
what I say
so for me what makes me who I am because
my mission is very different than yours
or anybody else's
I have to go into a situation okay
I'm a guy who wants to make people
better
for people to get better I have to
continuously get better myself
for me to do that I can't just say oh I
have this resume the resume is there
forever I'm good
I have to cap My Success because for me
to help people out I can't just say I
did it once
and I'm good I have to continue to
reinvent the will of the Mind
and figure out more and more ways for
you to pull because if I have a cookie
cutter message it may hit five people
out of 25. you just failed
my message needs to be in a way where I
can hit all 25 people it needs to be
broad enough
to where all 25 people may not like the
message but they're getting something
from it and that is evolution you must
continue to evolve and you don't evolve
from me in my job unless I cap myself
somewhere and say okay you made this
much money get back to [__] work
it's time to get back to work
stop hearing yourself talk get off the
podcast don't be on social media too
much cut out all the [__] noise get
back to the [__] mental lab because
that's where the knowledge came from so
for me I must cap myself so I can come
back with better more unique knowledge
versus the you know all that cookie
cutter knowledge that's out there
that's why people buy the books I have
because it's not cookie cutter it's real
knowledge the other thing now is
when you first started
you were a Lone Ranger right nobody
really knew who you were outside of some
obscure endurance places and half-hard
truths of these weird myths right but
now you've got people's expectations lay
it on top as well so not only have you
got to deal with success potentially
making you soft so you've got to cap
that you've got to say no to more money
and opportunities and cool people right
you've also got this extra layer of
expectation that's coming through from
other people too and I think that you
talk about trained humility right in the
new book too I've got to presume that
that
fits into this equation right it fits in
big time
um and that's one big reason why I do
fight fire
because the all the knowledge for myself
comes from that place it doesn't come
from the place of success my knowledge
does not come from a place like because
for me like I built Goggins from the
ground up I was born David Goggins David
Goggins wasn't good enough
he was a scared bullied
uh abused kid who struggled in life
and that kid whenever something got
tough no matter how hard I trained no
matter how ready I was
whenever something got tough for me
David Goggins the real David Goggins
would come out and he would quit
so I realized this over a period of time
so I had to build Goggins
and in that process
I have to go back to that mental lab in
that mental lab is at scratch that
mental lab isn't that trained humility
and so that's where I get better
I get better when I'm digging holes in
the ground when I'm waking up early
knowing I don't have to do these things
that's where I get better so it's
important to stay hungry it's important
to stay hungry but it's important more
to stay humble within that hunger
so while you're hungry a lot of people
are hungry
but humility is everything
what was that story about William
Crawford the janitor yeah so this guy
won the Medal of Honor
so he won the Medal of Honor and which
is the highest award in the military
and this guy went to the Air Force
Academy
and he was a janitor
and no one knew who the [__] this man
was he had the highest award in all the
military for heroics
for heroics saving lives putting his
life in the line could have you know
could have been killed
and he is now basically
you know cleaning [__]
for young kids
and we can all imagine how that probably
went you know there's probably some you
know a little bit of taunting here and
there and he just sat there and cleaned
the [__]
so that's why he's in my trained
humility part because for this man to be
at the level he was and have that kind
of humility to go I'm in the middle of
Honor winner but I'm gonna put that in
my closet and I'm gonna pick up my broom
and dustpan and I'm gonna pick up you
know this Rag and clean this [__] for
these young men
that right there is amazing for me man
that's that's where you grow that's
that's growth huge growth and also it
shows that he was doing his job
he was a servant
he didn't look at himself any better
than anybody else the second you do that
you totally lost
you cannot look at yourself like people
with me even
I always look at people I I know where
you are I know where because I've been
there
that's why I helped so many people out
I've I've never been above you I've
always pretty much been beneath you and
that's where my knowledge came from so I
know how to reach those people who are
in the dungeon
because I've been there so many times
this episode is brought to you by
element element is a tasty electrolyte
drink mix with everything that you need
and nothing that you don't I've replaced
my morning coffee with element every day
for over three years now and I've never
looked back it means I've optimized my
hydration my brain feels better I'm not
getting mental fog and it's helping me
to curb Cravings if I'm fasting
throughout the day even video guy Dean
uses it my favorite flavor is the orange
that in a cold glass of water upon
waking feels really really good it's a
science-backed electrolyte ratio of
sodium potassium and magnesium which
helps me to fill up my absolute best all
day also they have a no BS no questions
asked refund policy so you can buy it
and try it for an unlimited amount of
time and if you do not like it they'll
give you your money back and you don't
even need to return the box that's how
confident they are that you love it head
to drink
lmnt.com modern wisdom to get a free
sample pack of all eight flavors with
your first box that's drink lmnt.com
slash modern wisdom thank you very much
for tuning in if you enjoyed that clip
with Goggins then press here for the
full episode in all of its glory and
don't forget to subscribe
[Music]